hello fosdem i'm dmitry malshev i'm a
graphics engineer at mozilla
and i'm gonna dive into the history of
web gpu
with you fortunately and if you survive
i'm gonna show you how we use rasternet
so so this is a fairly long agenda
i hope we're going to get at least 2.4
here
the most interesting stuff is at 0.5 so
we'll try to keep the pace
is the screenshot from red dead
redemption and
what i want is for us to be able to
write code
graphics code which would produce a
similar picture
on all platforms including the web today
is not impossible at all
if you use a commercial engine like the
one that rockstar uses
then you may be able to reach consoles
and
some of the desktop platforms not all of
them and
you will not reach the web by that so
this is a very very unreachable goal
today
and this is what we are trying to fix in
the web gpu
working group
the api that is today that is portable
is opengl unfortunately
opengl is dying
and
every vendor tries to implement their
falcon drivers in such a way that opengl
is just an afterthought
and nobody optimizes for opengl and it
has
very many limitations that i try to
express
the only good thing about opengl is that
you can target the web with it today
with some limited subset of it
many concepts of opengl survived through
the beginning
and they are very far from either the
way hardware works
or the way we think about graphics
programming so
it's not a protocol for us graphics
engineer to
engineers to talk to the modern hardware
today
microsoft is not officially supporting
opengl
and it's forbidden in the universal
windows platform
webgl actually works via d3d11
on the most popular platform and apple
officially deprecated it
so you can make conclusions from here
this is a more technical slide
we can't use multiple cores
we can't predict where the driver is
gonna
try to freeze us for hundreds of
milliseconds
optimizing for mobile is a challenge
data transfers is a an art
and webgl 2 is not even portably
supported
opengl evolved in such a way that allows
you to skip it and do more on the gpu
and that path that does not allow rich
worlds like the one that i showed you in
the beginning where
there is like thousands of small objects
with different materials this is just
not acceptable
so the first question has anyone heard
the fact that
apple started web gpu yes
two people great um this is not correct
um it couldn't be farther from truth the
only thing that
apple started with web gpu is the name
which the group took from apple
so this is how it started 2016 vancouver
we gathered around the browser vendors
intel
a few more folks and we didn't know what
we were doing
we were trying to figure out is there a
way to design
an api that wouldn't be as complex as
vulcan while still be portable and
maybe target the web because you know
webgl is technically a chronos
project and opengl and vulkan are both
corners projects so this was in the
chronos meeting
and browser vendors came with their own
proposals on what this is going to look
like
we mozilla brought something called
web metal it worked
on top of vulcan apple brought something
that's worked very similarly like metal
and they quickly implemented it in
safari preview
now all of that code that they
prototyped is gone
our code was implemented on top of servo
and it's also gone
and google brought something original
that they called nxt
and there were some heated discussions
on where do we go from from there
the main conclusion was we couldn't work
with chronos
because reasons those
are something that we cannot explain
so apple created a w3c group
and invited pretty much the same people
as have been working
on that so we moved to the group
and started debating basic principles of
how apis should be designed
in 2017 we agreed on the binding model
which is critical
for us because we didn't want to agree
on the shading language and having the
binding model allows us to decide that
later
or never i don't know
maybe even next week we'll see so
2018 we agreed on implicit barriers
which is important for setting the
direction
of how the api uh how simple this is
going to be
to be used because vulcan and d312
require you to
explicitly transition your resources
between states and synchronization
synchronize between pipeline stages in
2018 we started
rust project called wgpu which
implements
a gpu for native platforms and in 19 a
year
from there we started integrating it
into gecko
and use it as a basis for web gpu
implementation in gecko
and gecko is the engine for firefox in
case
i haven't seen that
the basic principle is we try to
intersect the apis and see
which parts are portable which parts can
be executed on all of them
in the end we converged to basically
metal with vulcan binding model but
again this was not
coming from a single api this was coming
from outside and trying to find
the sweet spot
you know the comic about the 15th
standard that was the main feedback we
got from developers please
don't do any more mpis we're
there's too many um sorry we did
and it is going to happen
and we believe in it and we believe that
that new api is actually needed because
it's going to be the new era opengl sort
of thing it's going to be something that
you would be able to target all of the
platforms
with not much effort which you can
explain to your kids
and they can understand your code
so today as i said only opengl is
close to that but it's dying so that's
what web gpu is trying to be
the principles we followed for designing
it
obviously performance everybody says
performance nobody knows how to judge it
between the others
so security means that we validate all
the inputs
we don't allow anything to come to the
driver that the driver doesn't know what
to do with so in case of
vulcan validation we require the
workloads
to reach the driver with zero validation
warnings or errors
it also means that we need to sanitize
the shader out of bound access
and lots of things which may potentially
make your
programs slower but we're trying our
best to reduce this overhead to the
minimum
and portability is the most tricky part
at least it took me a while
maybe a few years to understand what
this means so
this means that programs are not only
compiled on all platforms
they behave similarly like if you have a
use case
and you api tells you that there is an
optimization for your use case
then you nee you can expect that it's
not going to be slower on
some platform because of that
optimization so this is not the case for
any other apis any other fps request
require you to discover the features
on the platform we are running on and
use those features so
we expose features in such a way that if
it matches your use case
and you use it you can we can guarantee
that it's going to be not slower or
likely faster
and obviously we want it to be usable as
i said we want it to be a teachable api
we want
people to understand what they write
these are early native benchmarks of the
aquarium demo
many people may have seen it in webgl
world
done by intel um not very convincing
but it's basically 10 to 30 percent it's
very early
benchmarking is one of the areas where
we are still lacking and we're gonna
catch up to that
so the other numbers apple gave us are
more convincing but i don't know if we
can seriously take them
um you can see like sometimes
performance on
number of triangles and i'm not sure why
number of triangles would be
different because it's any way reaching
the gpu and gpu is going to do this
the work but that's the numbers they
they have
now we're going to go through a example
of
a rust program in written against
wgpu.rs
explaining what this means and how it
works
so this is initialization which means we
create an adapter and we create a device
an adapter represents
sort of a physical instance of your
hardware
you can say and the device is a logical
instance that you work with that owns
all the resources
so we can say we want no power
preference and we want
any kind of back end which the back end
can be d3d12
vulcan or not all um
and we request the device with some
features and we get the device
these operations are in the api they are
asynchronous in the in our wrapper so
far there are synchronous we're going to
change that
now the swap chain initialization is
completely separate from the device
this is for any of you who only know
opengl can be
weird because you don't have to have a
swap chain you can do compute only work
loads without even caring about
presenting anything
so this is optional if you need to
present something you create your swap
chain based on the surface
that you get from the window
we create the data and the important bit
here
for buffer creation we specify what this
buffer is going to use to
in which case the vertex means it's
going to be used as a vertex satellites
buffer
and this is a descriptor of the vertex
data that we're going to
use later on um note that the descriptor
is separated from the actual data
in opengl where you provide those
layouts you provide a pointer to the
data
which doesn't make sense for the
hardware
explicit apis is a long topic but i
guess by this point you realize that the
answer is now
like all the headlines
this is an example in vulcan in order to
create an image
you have to go through four steps or
five
you figure out what the requirements are
you create logical image you find your
memory pools allocate memory and then
bind them to image so
there's a lot of going on and this is
not something simple people make
mistakes all the time
in that and in web gpu is just one
command of course
by hiding this we introduce some level
of uncertainty
maybe you will not have enough memory
and we will have to allocate more
this is the the balance that we reached
so far
and this is a highly subjective scale
that will allow you to reason about what
web gpu is and why we are doing this
the most performant versus the easier of
use api is vulcan
it's close to the hardware it's not
exactly hardware um
and opengl is sort of
neither it's it's easy but it's not
performant
battle is pretty good it's both and i
can talk more about metal
after the talk and web gpu is sort of
trying to get the best
of the world here
so we're separating data from the layout
of the data and this is the
bind groups mind groups is sort of
descriptor set in vulcan or
a range of descriptors in d3d12
which has a number of resources that you
bind at once
that's why it bound as a group
and we create the bind group by
providing the exact buffer that we just
created
and this is the explanation of why we
need the bind groups
the shaders communicate with bind groups
at the bottom
they get input from the vertex buffers
to the left and
they render to render targets at the top
now we're going to talk about pipelines
um why do we need pipelines if you ask
if you
used opengl only historically
the graphics hardware was just having
fixed function pipeline
it no it knew how to shade simply
some triangles and then some of the
stages
became more programmable then they
became even more programmable and then
they became
united into compute stages and then more
and more fixed function
stages that were left internally the
drivers started to convert to code
and linked to the whole shader stages
that they have so
when you switch your blend mode in
opengl this is not a simple switch the
driver will need to
internally rebuild your complete program
reallocate registers
and do crazy amount of work just to let
your next throw call to pass
so the pipeline is a concept that
gets the shooter with all the dependent
structures that it needs to work with
and
forces you to declare them in advance so
when you create the pipeline you expect
it to be slow
and you have to specify what your vertex
buffer layout is but not the data
what your render target format is but
not the data and again what your bind
group layouts is
finally the vertex buffer thing is
something that we consider
to not have try to imagine yourself
programming
a model without versus buffers maybe you
will have to i don't know
the problem is that it's very difficult
to make them secure
out of bound access is not covered by
auto bound extensions for vertex buffers
and
it's complex so we're still trying to
figure this out we will try to keep them
is how we create pipeline as i said we
have to specify
all of the state that your shader
depends on which
is the your render target information
vertex buffer information
your shaders and pipeline layout which
includes all the resources that your
sheeter sees
based on the stages so you declare all
of that at once again this is rust code
it uses enums it uses
references for me it's pretty readable
to work with
now we have rendering has render passes
which means that you don't just bind
a target and draw render passes are
needed
because mobile devices where there is
fast memory and they don't want to work
with the whole screen at once
loading pixels into this fast and cheap
memory is
heavy it's slow processing them is
cheaper
and so typically it would go tile by
tile and it would load all the pixels
that you have on the target
it would run your shaders on it and then
it would store them back into the tile
loading and storing is memory intensive
operation that is
very slow and therefore
you can control it you can say don't
load anything for me don't store
anything for me just clear it to this
color
which means you're saving a lot of
memory bandwidth this is the thing that
is acknowledged by all of the native
apis today
it was from the beginning in both vulcan
and metal
and lately it will get added to d312 the
latest version also has
render passes and you can see here how
we are creating a render path and we
specify
we are specifying the load operation to
be clear which means we don't want to
to be loaded we just want to clear
we specify the clear color inside the
render paths we do all the rendering and
we set all the state which is the
pipeline
the bind group index vertex buffers and
issuing the draw call
the beauty of this setup is that by the
time we call
draw indexed all the state that it
depends on is already set
through index is blazingly fast it's
there is nothing that's going on in the
draw index
other than maybe some vertex buffer
validation that i mentioned
and you can you are supposed to be able
to
issue thousands tens of thousands of
draw calls
in big fat render passes
this is the goal that would allow us to
let to produce those
you know shiny pictures
see that um multi-threading is something
that all of the new apis support
in this example there's three threads
involved on the first thread we recorded
this big render pass that we just talked
about
on the second thread we compute some we
record some compute work
and um at this stage where we compute it
we don't know when exactly it's going to
be executed we just tell it what to do
but then we send it to the thread that
owns the queue and we say submit first
and then second this is where the order
is set up
so all of these can be on separate
threads
this this is especially important on
again on mobile devices where we have
lots of threads but maybe not so
powerful threads
this is how it's done in code you create
an encoder the encoder can then
have some compute or render passes you
finish encoder you get the command
buffer which you can send
to the queue or just provide the queue
directly and submission is
getting a array of them
implicit barriers is something i
mentioned as well so if
here you can see that we have four
different pieces in the command stream
and
the usage of texture and the buffer
changes between the operations
some of the usages can be combined these
are read only usages
like in this 3d 12 mutable usages cannot
be combined if you try to combine them
within the render pass
which is the synchronization scope for
us we will trigger an error
and you will not have what you need
um wsl is that our shipping language i
mentioned that we haven't figured out
yet
no it's not it's just a proposal from
apple
uh mostly we're discussing whether we
can accept it or not
we don't have hidden language as i
mentioned we don't support multiple
queues which would be
important for a sync compute which you
kinda can do
already but multiple queues make it
nicer and our data transfers between cpu
and
gpu are not optimal yet it's hard to
figure those out in terms of the
security not allowing cpu and gpu to
race
to change and inspect the data because
this racing introduces non-portable
behavior potentially unsecured behavior
this is the main question
you think it's only for the web who
thinks it's only for the web
nobody great because that's the main
point of confusion i've seen
every person that has heard of web gpu
says oh it's another web thing i'm not
gonna touch it
okay so the working group is
designing it for the web but what we
realized as in
mozilla and google at least is that it's
a very good
api for native platforms as well as i
mentioned the new kind of opengl thing
so we are working on shared headers the
c headers
that you will be able to link to so that
you can use interchangeably either
our implementation or google's
implementation on native platforms
in fact people have already shipped
applications on app store using our
implementation
on native only without any web stuff so
oh this is supposed to be demo time oh
that's gonna be fun okay
okay we're here
so this is generating mid-maps where i
will explain why it's complex
later
this is some two shadows
you can see some validation errors which
were discovered to be
validation error validation layer bugs
which is fun
and this is
i wonder if it's oh it's loaded on my
machine
great how do i show it to you
yep yep
oh great it didn't go well
okay so this is like 10 000
objects with some ray tracing and a lot
of other good stuff and physics
and it's all running on falcon on my
machine it's equally well running on
d312 and metal
all right now back
[Applause]
thank you now i hit something
that i wasn't supposed to um
if you don't know what gfx is
i encourage you to rewind back time
two years before where on this track me
and marcus from gfx team were
describing what this is on a very
similar slide
so one problem that we had with gfx that
is solved here
is that if your rendering depends on the
back end and we use generics for the
back end
then it becomes contagious and you have
to have all of your game depending on
the backend type which is
very inconvenient and you can switch
back and set frame time if you want to
what we came up with is um
a macro so there is a ec function and we
expose the c api
that gets the id
figures out what the back end it needs
and just checks
the back end in a match and calls the
appropriate generic function device
create buffer here
so this is what we use internally this
is just the means
for your perspective nothing is generic
you just work with web
you don't even know what backend it is
until you ask so it will choose one that
works best for you automatically
this is what id looks like you can see
the last three bits is the back end
in the middle there is epoch so that we
can reuse indices
in case your resources perish and we
need to recreate them
and those tables of actual data that we
have
they are back in specific so we have a
table
of buffers for vulcan table of buffers
for metal and so forth
usage structure helps us to
figure out how resources transition from
one usage to another
and this scheme we came up with this uh
that each tracker
knows about correspondence to indices to
states and the state is again a map of
sub-resources to usage and why do we
need sub-resources
sub-resource a texture can have many
mid-map levels
each meeping level can have many layers
each of those can have its own states
if we go deeper depth and stencil in
some variations of apis can also have
different states that's the like
the third dimension and this is
um this sounds trivial but it's fairly
complex to implement at least google
hasn't yet
and we have and that's why i mentioned
that mid map generation is
sort of hard because you change the
usage and one micmap does not equal to
the usage of another mid-map when you
generate it so
this is how we define the scopes
the errors i inserted is where we try to
insert a synchronization in the command
stream
and the interesting bit here is that
render pass is a whole scope
copy operation is single scope but
compute pass is not a whole scope
and that that matches behavior by
default in metal
and it's it's really tricky because
we are trying to minimize the the risk
of um
races and what what we do we synchronize
between these patches if there is the
same
resource used as a storage for example
and you can use resources for different
usages within
a pass but you can argue that
within a single dispatch call there may
be multiple races on the gpu
and we don't protect you from that
so there's always this you know scale of
where to throw
draw the line and in this particular
case we decided to draw
throw it between dispatches we may
introduce an option
to like have compute pass as a single
scope
it's not a big deal for us but it
affects you so
that's how it looks today and when we
patch between those scopes
we know where each scope expects the
usage to be and
that's the expected value and we push
between those
between those so the bind group and
render pass usages are all
combined they can be mutated inside um
and the command buffer and device usages
are transitioned one from another
so this this is a different logic and
what we were
trying very hard to express
is using the rust type system right
between this is different logic why
don't you use generics you ask
so we had three attempts to
implement it using genetics and it you
can get it to work
but it's not looking pretty at all so
what we ended up doing this slide is
should not be here
i think i explained it before about
mipmaps so
what we end up with is just runtime
thing as you can see the
initial state is an option which means
if you want to transition it to a
different one we remember what the
initial state was
and you may wonder why it's so simple
what are you showing me here
as i mentioned there was like multiple
tries to use
rust type system they ended up being
very complex hardly maintainable code
so this solution is super simple it's
straightforward everybody can
see what it's doing it's more generic
it's an example of how
solving a more generic problem gives you
a simpler solution and i think
it's a it's a good example of that
we track resources uh for the user
so user has one link to a resource
device has one link to resource and then
everything else like commands and bind
groups have different links um
once those other links including the
user one
go away and device is the sole
owner of the resource we figure out what
was the last submission
the resource was used and we associated
with this submission then
periodically we check the submission to
see oh is it done yet
and if it's done then that's the time
where we actually release the resource
and try to recycle its memory this is
all done automatically for you
this is the structure of wgpu um
many ways here i'm trying to explain the
main ones so the one that we have now is
the only one going from double
gpu rs which is our rust wrapper to the
native which is the implementation or c
api implementation
that goes into core which goes into gfx
what we will have is that wgpu rs will
call websis and will allow you to target
the web directly without going tram
scripted or anything
alternatively you can use them scripting
to target
uh the web or you can use the
shared path between web gpu native and
dawn because
they share the same c headers and you
can run on top of
google's implementation
enamels are beautiful i i think
everybody understands that
and they work very well for us render
past resources the
the problem we have is that within the
past we don't want to reference
resources
but the api requires us to hold them
alive
and that's three key because we don't
want that overhead as i said you can
have 10 000
draw calls in the same render pass we
don't want for each draw call try to
lock those resources and keep them alive
so we enforce the lifetimes they give it
to us
or at least for us for free but
you pay for the headache because you're
going to use that and
lifetimes is not something that people
love to see errors about but actually
it's fairly
straightforward so what we ended up with
is a system
where rust allows us to express those
optimization guarantees
with you and if you need them to be held
you do it on your side typically you
don't so you don't pay anything for that
command encoders are they have special
marker that does not let them to be
moved or synced
um automatically because send and sync
are
auto trades so this prevents those auto
trades and
this allows us to enforce the guarantee
that when you're encoding you're not
moving between threads or you're not
doing it
unsynchronized we
use a lot of borrowing and the the
pretty thing is that when we generate
the c
header we can still use external c
functions with borrowing
it translates to a pointer but not
slices just
regular things this is one of the
most complex bits we have so as i
mentioned
our low level structures are placed in
arrays and we lock those
arrays in order to access them and you
can imagine a case where the locks go in
the wrong order
that did happen so we ended up with type
level lock order protection
which is here the token i um try to
highlight
including the one that failed to
highlight these are
all different types as in they depend on
the different genetic and that generic
changes
it shows the code what is
accessible to lock so if you're trying
to lock something weird your code will
not compile
if your code compiles it doesn't have
phrase conditions and
deadlocks
we use parking lot which was mentioned
already uh great stuff
uh various arrays c by engine that i
mentioned for examples we use we need
and of course we're based on gfx and a
bit of friendly just the descriptor
and memory stuff of randy
as i mentioned you can have externship
function with the borrowed
pointer but you can have slices and
that's very annoying we have a lot of
slices
and always converts in between slices
and
pointers is not pretty so i would love
that to be better
and the one lesson that i want to tell
you is
like rust community is that we concluded
that genetics are not always good
um maybe it's obvious for you we used a
ton of genetics in gfx and
on webview we're trying to minimize that
um generics slow down the compilation
time
and they limit the user quite a bit
um they make it difficult to work with
the code
so we're trying to do less of them
so i mentioned we are going to target
websites directly that's one of the
things
error handling is bare bones we have
asserts somewhere results but all of
that is going to be replaced by the
proper error model in the api which is
the internal nullability
which means if you're trying to do
something illegal to an object like
you created a buffer with the wrong
descriptor then it may be
internally invalid you can ask it
whether it's valid or not but you might
as well just continue your
recording and pretend that it's valid
only to discover it later
and the reason it's done is because we
can't give it to you synchronously
and we can't let you block so you can we
kind of let you go
and then when you're ready you're gonna
check whether
your workload is valid or not on our
site are not going to
do any invalid work of course if we if
we see during command buffer encoding
that you used in valid buffer
your cool command buffer becomes invalid
um we very much would like to target
opengl
as well it's it's technically a target
for us but
it's rough we don't recommend people to
use it we don't even expose it via the
rust wrapper yet
so more work coming
there is a summer of code project that
is related to that so maybe in half a
year the situation is going to be better
ideally we would target webgl
2.0 by web gpu which is going to be fun
as well
these are some links of the projects uh
at the top there is a
spec repo i'm one of the editors for the
spec
and the there is the web gpu headers at
the bottom and there is
our previous talk about gfx at the
bottom
so now we have we have time
we're going to talk about browsers
[Music]
this is how gecko is structured today
you can see it
in nightly
we have a small crate which call which
is called
wgp remote which allows you to record
passes
and
create ids and allow the content process
to manage ids and passes and the gpu
process to actually execute them
so this is a fairly simple structure but
the point is
web gpu is used across multiple
processes
this is an example of how it's done so
the client creates an id
it sends it to both javascript
and the server and the cro server will
only afterwards
actually create the buffer
render pass recording as i mentioned is
completely on the client side so while
you create your render pass
it's super lightweight it doesn't take
anything we use
peak poke serialization library i know
everybody uses surveys so peak poke is a
kind of dark horse alternative it's not
recommended to be used it's only used by
webrender today and web gpu
we'll try to make it more accessible
it's just slightly faster
and then when render pass is done we
send the whole thing
via shared memory to gpu process which
actually executes commands
there is a lot going on here that is
that you don't see
um imagine that the barrier between
processes
involves a code generation change in c
plus plus
the barrier between javascript involves
a code phase in
javascript bindings and between each of
those there is a
c to rust boundary so we we cross like
four different boundaries across the
stack
um it's fairly annoying and we're trying
to get it better
this is a subjective measure of
completeness between browsers
chromium is fairly good they have a
large team
and they are they have a lot of api
surface implemented
we just got the compute working
you can get you can get the nightly
go to the prefs enable web gpu and run
the compute example that everyone
that chrome does um we will work on
presentation rendering next
and servo is also catching up for servo
catching up is fairly simple because
it's pure rust you don't have as many
barriers that i mentioned
but it's using the same infrastructure
it's using wgbu
and i'd like to thank some people my gfx
team
wgpu community josh especially
and currency from google for helping out
on the spec and with the slides
so that's it i think we've been finished
early